jours sylvain rousseau envoyé spécial de
france 24 à kiev l'armée ukrainienne dit
se préparer à ce qu'elle appelle déjà la
grande bataille de l'est
oui effectivement la grande bataille de
l'est en ce qu'on annonce ici un peu
partout c'est ce qui sera probablement
la plus grande bataille sur le sol
européen depuis la fin de la deuxième
guerre mondiale a lancé les troupes
russes sont retirés de la région de kiev
retirer du nord du pays après plusieurs
semaines de combats pour se regrouper
dans l'est du pays et lancer ainsi une
grande offensive sur toute la région du
dombass qui est depuis l'échec des
troupes russes à prendre la capitale
kiev et bien cette région du donbass est
venu l'objectif militaire numéro 1
l'objectif minimal presque pour pour
vladimir pour vladimir poutine on le
voit très bien ici à kiev ce retrait des
troupes russes je vous donner un exemple
nous avions une équipe de journalistes
qui étaient là il ya quelques semaines
et pour faire la route entre le vivent
et kiev et bien ils ont dû prendre des
chemins détournés ils ont dû prendre une
route très long pour éviter la route la
plus rapide au nord qui étaient tenues
qui était pilonnée par par les forces
russes eh bien nous nous avons pu passer
par cette route et il a juste fallu
faire un détour à la fin de la route
pour éviter des villes détruites des
ponts détruits qui ne nous permettaient
pas de rejoindre kiev mais cette route
est aujourd'hui tout à fait tout à fait
praticable alors on se prépare pour quoi
se prépare-t-on à une aussi grande et
une aussi longue surtout bataille dans
l'est de l'ukraine et bien parce que les
ukrainiens du côté ukrainien le moral
est au beau fixe après le retrait des
troupes russes de la capitale et les
ukrainiens profitent de cette relative
accalmie également sur sur le sur la
partie occidentale du pays pour se faire
livrer beaucoup d'armement pour se
réarmer pour se réapprovisionner ce sont
les meilleures troupes ukrainienne les
mieux préparés qu'ils vont faire face à
des troupes russes qui ont déjà livré
bataille et qui elles seront peut-être
un petit peu plus fatigué notamment avec
un temps de transport extrêmement long
mais ne croyez pas que la situation que
la situation est totalement est
totalement en paix dans le reste du pays
on attend aussi on s'attend à ce que les
grandes villes et notamment kiev la
capitale soit aussi bombardé au moment
de cette attaque pour pour faire
diversion pour désorganiser
principalement les forces de sécurité et
les secours ukrainien et pour que les
russes aient bien titans de tout ce qui
est en leur pouvoir pour pour prendre ce
bon base dans ce que vous appelez
effectivement ce qu'on appelle déjà la
grande bataille de l'est merci sylvain
rousseau envoyé spécial de france 24 à
kiev voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire